escalar de la copa américa femenina esta
semana conocimos los emparejamientos de
este torneo que se disputa en julio aquí
en colombia las anfitrionas están en el
grupo a con chile ecuador paraguay y
bolivia al grupo b brasil perú venezuela
argentina y uruguay sara cuál es el
proceso de las selecciones sudamericanas
en la antesala de esta copa américa
femenina partimos hablando de brasil que
por cultura futbolística evidentemente
ha tenido un adelanto con respecto al
resto de selecciones de sudamérica pero
luego yo creo que lo que va a pasar con
colombia es muy interesante justo cuando
la federación colombiana de fútbol
buscaba hacer la sede del mundial las
futbolistas incluso a pesar de todas las
contradicciones y reclamos que han hecho
les parecía que era el momento
fundamental para avanzar muchos años en
estos procesos porque lo que está otra
vez atención tanto del público de la
dirigencia y demás yo creo que es muy
interesante ver lo que está haciendo
venezuela con pamela conti como
entrenadora principal y su hermano no
solo siendo asistente sino que hoy en
día está dirigiendo la selección sub-20
chile la mejor portera del mundo y
también un proceso de atrás muy serio y
lo de ecuador se ve reflejado en la
selección de mayores de hombres y en
ellos tiene una estructura muy
interesante trajeron a una técnica
brasilera como demi emily lima y creo
que a partir de ahí están construyendo
vamos a ver una copa américa mucho más
competitiva en la que se juegan por
supuesto tres cupos directos al mundial
el primero de ellos que va a los juegos
olímpicos un evento muy importante para
el desarrollo del fútbol femenino y
sudamérica a partir de algo que hemos
hablado muy claramente acá y es que el
mundial de 2019 en francia nos dejó ya
unas expectativas y unos estándares muy
altos para el manejo del fútbol femenino
desde el punto de vista del mercadeo de
la industria y por supuesto de lo
deportivo mucha presión también para
colombia' las anfitrionas que tienen
también un proceso muy largo a ver si
pueden cumplir ese papel de defender su
casa sara